[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the world famous bonus show
two people in france do watch so we can
technically uh technically say that
uh no i don't know what i'm talking
about it's people in france watch we
have a big big french audience ukraine
says that russia's offensive in donbass
has started
and you know i think maybe to kind of
reset the stage here
there were all these reports from a few
weeks ago that russia could really only
um handle about another 10 days at the
level at which they were operating and
then something was going to break and a
lot of people now are saying like well
what happened to those 10 days because
it's still going on that's true and
without saying that those predictions
were correct or incorrect pat the scope
of what's going on has changed pretty
significantly there's there's been a
change to the degree
of air strikes being used there's a
change to the speed at which russian
troops are moving
we also don't have complete information
about everything that's exactly going on
so i don't even pretend at this point to
be able to say with certitude like kind
of how is it going yeah and obviously
there's fog of war at the very beginning
of this thing there were reports about
how europe was worried that kiev could
fall within a matter of hours or days
and that turned out to obviously not be
true because the resistance in ukraine
was so strong
and then of course we did have a bunch
of shelling in kharkiv and kiev and
these other places but now it does seem
to be a lot more confined into that
donbass region of ukraine and it makes
sense given that russia was failing
throughout the country
and so if they decide now that okay
we're not going to be able to take over
the entire country but maybe we can get
the donbass region
it does make sense that they would sort
of centralize their forces there and
most likely have more success because
they're doing that what i guess we if we
ask the question
what can we say for sure about how it's
going it would be
all of the predictions that in like five
days russia would take ukraine
clearly that was wrong and so if that
was your starting point
it has gone better than that for ukraine
and beyond that there's really a lot of
questions as to what the path forward is
the um the donbass region
is right on the russian border and it's
alongside the donetsk and luhansk areas
uh the luhansk area touch touches russia
uh the dinettes location
is a little bit south and west of that
and the donbass region is right up on
the russian border one interpretation of
this is that russia is kind of
realigning its objectives and is now
saying as you're kind of pointing out
let's just see if we can consolidate
control of luhans donetsk and the and
the donbass region
and maybe the broader ambition is
postponed for the future but again we're
trying to make sense out of an invasion
that doesn't even make any sense
yeah or maybe uh postponed indefinitely
they'll never try this again because it
failed so miserably the russians
reportedly have about 75 percent of
their combat power remaining from the
start of the invasion
which i mean that's that's a crazy
amount to be reduced to right
i mean perhaps they voluntarily withdrew
some of those troops and that's why
because you know if they're only going
to be focusing on those eastern regions
and ukraine maybe you don't need as many
but it also suggests that maybe they've
just taken a bunch of losses a bunch of
casualties tanks blown up and and that
sort of thing too
and
that's obviously not sustainable because
you know if ukraine is able to continue
to fight back with that amount of force
they're going to continue to decimate
the russian army and within a matter of
months maybe russia will have no choice
but to withdraw yeah the question is how
much of a loss has ukraine suffered and
it's harder to even answer the question
because you have you know you've got
whatever that group is that malcolm
nance is part of you've got these random
foreign fighters and legions and all
these different things and so it's hard
to really like even measure it because
at least in theory because there's such
support for ukraine which is waging a
defensive war here
that it's almost like the entire global
population is at least in theory
potentially going to join the fight
although not everybody yep in ukraine
obviously they have a limited amount of
personnel yeah you can only attract so
many people to physically join the cause
but it seems like they have basically an
unlimited amount of resources when it
comes to you know supplies and that sort
of thing whereas russia it's going to
get depleted and there's no there's no
one going to save them right whereas
ukraine we have the us we have nato we
have so many different forces who are
willing to back them so this thing could
go on for a long time and it's
interesting too because like many people
who live in those eastern regions in
ukraine if you ask them before all this
started if they would want to
voluntarily join russia i'd imagine the
polling would suggest that they would uh
but at this point because they're being
shelled and attacked non-stop that that
can't be good for public sentiment that
can't be good for making them want to
join russia at this point so i wonder if
that has changed too and if yeah um
there'll there really will be a push to
have that region stay with ukraine if
ukraine wants that if the people who
live in those areas want that if that
tide has turned as well i don't know
what the polling looked like before i
know part of what russia argued was a
majority wants to join russia russia
lies all the time so that may have been
true or maybe not but i think you're
right that whatever that number started
it has to have been diminished uh
through throughout this one other thing
you said this may not end any time soon
my sense is even if there's some quote
agreement reached
it's still not going to end because it
seems so unlikely that as part of an
agreement russia would completely leave
the donetsk and luhansk regions and then
forget about crimea so for me it seems
like the best case scenario would be an
agreement that just reduces hostilities
but i don't think russia's leaving
right i think tensions will just go cold
like they did after 2014 after crimea
was taken over it's not like they were
actively fighting against one another
but
it's still good to see right a ceasefire
people not getting killed day to day
that's hopefully what we're looking for
and obviously this goes back to that
conversation about how putin has to save
face because of course he is still a
nuclear threat and if we completely
embarrass him then he may feel inclined
to escalate so we don't want that either
let's talk about disney i hate theme
parks it's horrifying the food is
terrible the lines are terrible
the you're basically uh kind of held
captive by the corporate uh
overlords i just i just hate it i don't
like six flags disneyland disney world
or any of it
however
disney is now under fire for different
reasons including that they um denounced
florida's don't say gay bill and this
led to a a trumpist sort of rally type
event
holding flags protesting disney and now
florida governor ron desantis who's a
small government conservative
is moving to strip disney of power to
self-govern republicans have called a
special legislative session that was
scheduled to start yesterday
and the idea is to strip disney of its
ability to govern itself
and exactly what that means is kind of a
question mark uh
there's this weird infrastructure for
disney in in florida
where back in 1967
the florida legislature granted disney
the ability to form an independent
government to over uh to oversee its
theme parks now that's like kind of
weird uh and
what they now are looking to do
is to
review and eliminate that and
potentially this would have a
significant impact on the way that
disney operates and it's not really i
mean listen i you can argue that this
didn't make sense when it was done pat
but it's not really a small government
conservative thing to take that away and
say we now are going to take control
yeah i mean i think this mainly has to
do with them being able to run their
their own utility systems and emergency
services yes so if they take that away
like would disney even be all that upset
about it i don't know and then it's also
i guess not that conservative because
conservatives claim to be all about free
speech these days disney is a private
company has that right too to say what
they want to say about a particular bill
yeah and they're essentially being
punished because of them speaking but
obviously the right doesn't really care
about consistency when it comes to this
sort of thing and i gotta say like this
really um this really hits home for me
because my first memories as a human
being was when i went to disney world
when i went to florida in 1998 wow i
remember a few things i remember the
trams and i also remember the autographs
that you get from all the different
characters and i remember crying because
i wasn't allowed to go on the tower of
terror because i was too small when the
rest of my family was able to go on um
so yeah i mean this is a really
important story we have to cover this
one crying is a very common uh staple of
trips to uh to disney world i can tell
you from having having seen it when i
was there yeah i went to disney i want
to say when i was 12 and then again at
18. it's just not my thing i don't
really like roller coasters i don't
really like rides where you're kind of
like shaking around and i know that
there are some like really smooth rides
now like for example i remember at the
six flags in massachusetts where i grew
up there's like a batman ride and you
hang and you go in loops and all this
stuff but it's so smooth that it wasn't
bad but i remember like going on a basic
roller coaster at disney and it was so
jarring and bumpy that it was just i
just got a headache from it i didn't
like it it's just not for me i like
going to theme parks like once every
couple of years because i do like the
roller coasters i don't like the lines
and the other attractions and stuff but
the roller coasters are fun i just
haven't been so inclined to go to disney
because disney seems a lot more
kid-oriented right like they have some
good coasters i haven't been since i was
a little uh kid but i know adults
i know adults who go and they say no you
go to a couple rides but you go to the
high-end restaurants they treat it
almost like it's like a vegas sort of
thing um you know there's vacation clubs
and all this i just don't want to go i
don't want to go yeah that's just just
not for me also landlocked orlando i
mean come on guys we love our viewers in
orlando but i want to be on the water
yeah if you're going to florida or
florida yeah one either one got to go to
the beaches right like that's kind of
the whole point of why you're going
there so yeah i'm i'm much more of a fan
of southern florida miami and that sort
of area should even give me give me
tampa uh give me jacksonville honestly
at least that'll have some beaches i
love the beaches of pensacola we have
great friends of the show in pensacola
and uh pensacola beaches i mean you
can't go in january it's pretty far
north but uh it's it's quite a scene so
anyway we'll we'll see ultimately what
is how severely uh disney is punished
for their opinion which republicans are
against doing
except if they don't like your opinion
we talked about how former
wasilla alaska gov mayor
and
um
former vice presidential candidate sarah
palin palin was never the governor of
alaska she was she was how did i forget
that i just completely blanked so she
was right so she was mayor of wasilla
she quit that early to become governor
right no she was mayor of wasilla then
became governor and ran for vice
president oh right then after she gained
this um national notoriety yep she
decided to quit her job as governor of
alaska right into a reality man i
completely forgot that she was even the
governor that's how big of an impression
she made on me okay so sarah palin is
now running for house of representatives
for the seat previously held by the now
deceased don young
she is sort of the big celebrity
candidate and there was a thought when
she first announced she's going to run
away with this thing
it's not apparently happening there
number one seem to be a significant
number of alaskans that are bitter
because of her
bailing
on the the governorship as we were just
talking about
and in addition just like her star power
seems to have diminished she she's
called out of favor with many alaskans
she's also pretty trumpy and alaska has
a lot of trump stuff but alaska is kind
of different in terms of the
conservatism that you see there lisa
murkowski the senator is an example of
it she may not run away with this thing
pat which i think would be the end of
her political career yeah and we can say
that alaska is a red state but it's it's
really like a pink state where it trends
more independent yes lisa murkowski is
quite independent they do elect
democrats sometimes so it makes sense
that palin wouldn't just absolutely run
away with this thing but i think when we
all heard about her announcement and how
there were 50 candidates running many of
us just thought well okay she has the
name recognition so it does seem like it
would make sense for her to win but the
polls that have come out so far are
pretty tight um many have her in second
place behind independent al gross
and the system is kind of weird in
alaska they're going to have a primary
where the top four candidates will move
on to the general and then in the
general election it's actually ranked
choice voting so i wonder if that will
play a factor too because
like maybe there are deep conservatives
in alaska who pick someone else but have
palin second maybe they're going to be
more independent-minded people who would
take any conservative or any liberal
over palin because they think that she's
a quitter uh this is not a foregone
conclusion that she's going to win this
thing so a couple additional notes in
terms of favorability so this is not the
polling that pat mentioned but in terms
of favorability in alaska right now she
has a 31 positive 56 percent negative so
she's underwater by 25 points that's not
great
uh and in addition to that um the 50
candidates are now down to 48 so it
doesn't really mathematically change
anything she's still expected to be in
the top four and then it's going to be a
matter of how the campaign goes i think
she's absolutely horrible and
incompetent and ignorant i would like to
see her political career ended
yeah and i would like to see the same
for those very reasons but i gotta say i
do respect alaskans for trying to do
away with her because she quit on them
right like sure that does seem very
principled and it's not like she quit on
them for a good reason it wasn't like
you know there was something to deal
with in her family life or she actually
got elected vice president or those
would be legitimate reasons but to
launch your own reality show and you
know just sort of um walk away for
yourself walk away on the state like
they may not forgive you for that even
though it's been 10 years now one other
thing on alaska i don't know if this is
accurate i've spent plenty of time in
vermont but i've never been to alaska i
get the sense that some of the liberal
aspects of alaska are kind of similar to
the conservative aspects of vermont and
what i mean by that is vermont votes
very democratic
but has like higher gun ownership for
example but as bernie has explained it's
because of its like rural nature and
guns play a different role in vermont
than they do in a lot of places like
with cities for example
for me the kind of moderating influence
that makes vermont more center than most
new england states
feels similar to what makes alaska more
center than many red states although i
do i can't say for sure that that's
accurate
yep and alaska and vermont both have a
lot of transplants too a high percentage
of people who live there weren't born
there and
maybe there's some sort of factor with
all that too like the people who are
willing to up and leave their home state
maybe they're more independent-minded
maybe they want to live in the
wilderness and obviously if you're out
there in the middle of nowhere you kind
of need the gun because the police
aren't going to be around the corner to
help you and you know what if there's a
bear that attacks you or something like
that so yeah there's definitely that
component if you uh have spent time in
both vermont and alaska
write in and tell me whether my uh my
analysis
very ill-informed speculative analysis
has anything to it we'll see everybody
tomorrow